اخبار حرب غزه بايجاز من رفح اهلا بكم
وزاره الصحه تقول ان الاحتلال ارتكب 24
مجزره خلال 24 ساعه راح ضحيتها 210 شهداء
وذلك تزامنا مع قصف عنيف استهدف محيط
مستشفيي الامل والقدس في حين وصفت منظمه
الصحه العالميه وضع المشافي
بالكارثي المتحدثه باسم برنامج الاغذيه
تقول للجزيره ان الضع في غزه صعب جدا مع
تعثر وصول المساعدات في حين قالت الامم
المتحده في اليوم الدولي للتعليم ان اكثر
من
625 ال طالب في غزه محرومون من التعليم
منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اشهر نتنياهو يقول ان
اسرائيل يجب ان تنتصر وانها لن تخضع لما
وصفه بالارهاب وزعيم المعارضه يعتبر ان
النظام السياسي في اسرائيل هو المشكله
وليس الحل وذلك في ظل تحذيرات امميه ورفض
امريكي لاي تعد دائم على اراضي غزه بعد
الحديث عن مساع لاقامه منطقه عازله على
حدود
القطاع وفي الضفه الغربيه شهيد شرق طول
كرم ومصابون في مواجهات جنوب جنين
والاحتلال ينفذ اقتحامات في مدينه يطا
جنوب الخليل وقريه بيتين شمالي رام الله
ويعتقل 35 فلسطينيا منذ الليله الماضيه
الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]
i